"What did you do to me? Your body won't last long. You'll be stuck in there for the rest of your life"
"[cat] You get me out of here you son of a- [man] Calm down Mr. Brand. You're a cat. [cat] I hate cats"
I hate to waste my money or my time on something that is truly bad like
Suicide Squad bad, where every decision seems to be made for maximum shift
"Somethin' tells me a whole lot *beep* people are about to die."
It's a shame, but in the end, I think crappy movies are an inevitable part of the cinematic ecosystem.
You're not ever gonna get away from them.
And whether or not they make money, some of which unfortunately do,
No one is setting out to make a movie that is a piece of crap.
"I'm talking about a completely superfluous bottle of cough syrup...
That's like six bucks"
"Are you joking?"
What's more insidious in my opinion are movies that are just... Passable.
Films just good enough not to be terrible.
I mean passable films, they aren't bad they might even be better than okay
But they're a far cry from great, or noteworthy, or something that you would like to see more than once.
They're the cinematic equivalent of this image
They don't fall apart, but their balance is always precarious
In the last handful of years, my annoyance with passable movies has steadily increased in proportion
with their steadily increasing number
Passable films like to multiply.
They do just enough for the audience, and just enough for the studio, and just enough for the stars
They have no problem being funded.
[Kevin Hart] "Stop Stop! I need to know what is happening. Right now."
For a long time, I've attributed the major problem with passable movies  to a lack of tonal control.
the emotional logic of the narrative in films like these often, often feels a bit out of whack
Either the film tries to be too many things at once leading to unintended emotional confusion
"John Francis Walker, by authority of Governor Nicks...
this unit has been author..." [girl grunts] *CLANG* "ized..."
...to extinguish your life
*CLANG*CLANG*CLANG*
*CLANG**ZAPZAP*CLANG*ZAP*CLANG*
*zap*clang*clang*clang*clang*
*CLANG*GNALC*ZAP*ZAP*CLANG*CLANG
[man quietly] "oh..okay...okay..."
*CLANG*CLANG*
*still clanging & zapping*...
[Man]  "alright...thats enough. That's enough."
Or the filmmakers give characters traits that don't belong to them in order to serve some plot function
[Driver] "What has it been this year so far?...
...Bernie Madoff?...
...Two wars without end? Million people with no work? And that's just the first two weeks of January."
Or emotional arcs, initiated early in the story, are abandoned without comment
often proving in the end to be entirely pointless
In good movies, everything points to everything else.
The emotional arcs of the characters, the scenes, the imagery, the music and the plot are tightly entwined
And this doesn't just go for highbrow movies, by the way.
Whenever you hear someone say of a lower brow film that "it knows what it is"
What they're really saying is that the film was tonally focused.
On that, we agree
But recently, I've begun to notice another unifying feature of passable movies
Indeed, of all passable storytelling.
And to understand what I mean take a look at this scene:
"I gotta say it feels really good to have somebody looking out for me."
"I've got your back man"
"I like that...
...And I got your back, too"
"Hey Doug...
...I like you man. I think you're a great guy.
I just want you to remember that this is a business relationship...
Doesn't mean that. We're gonna be best friends. It's not how the story ends.
I'm just an employee with a job to do."
[Doug] "I get it.  You're not my best friend. You're just my best man."
"It doesn't mean we're not gonna have a good time, Doug!"
[Doug] "I said I got it!
"You're anybody's best friend for a price, but nobody's when it counts."
[Voice Over] All the beats in this short scene should be familiar to us we've seen them all before
But there's something odd going on here.
You see, stories are almost always about people
or aliens or gods or animals or robots that act like people
And great stories are always the ones that observe people truthfully
The ones that capture human experience with nuance and insight
And the best stories make such acute observations about humanity
that they can show us things about ourselves
that we didn't know or teach us how to articulate those things
Against a vast. Unintelligible. Anxiety
And this, I think, is the big difference between great movies and passable ones
When passable movies observe human experience, they observe it not through the lens of real life
But through the lens of other movies
"Love is my life."
"No! Love is your job!"
"You know, I think you're threatened by what Zoey and I have...
...because you're afraid I won't be able to hang out every night"
"You are my drug dealer...
...There's one reason we know each other. I like the drugs you sell. That's it"
There is this huge library. This huge vocabulary of actions built up over the years
That people you know
Don't really do but which happened so often in TV and movies
That they're familiar enough to an audience that they become, well...
passable for human motivations
I'm not saying it's bad for filmmakers to cite or pay homage to the movies that they love in their own work
I'm saying that too many films released today are being cobbled together from a weird alternate reality.
That is only a dim echo of our own.
I do not believe in Fairy tales about Chakras or energy
Or the power belief there is no such thing as spirit
This is the long-term danger of cliche.
The more we allow it to happen, the harder it is to escape
The more difficult it is for audiences and writers to tell the difference
The last thing we want is to see our own lives through the lens of art that's only passable
New perspectives are what we need.
Originality is what we should encourage at every chance.
Otherwise, I'm afraid our movies and ourselves will change into something quite different
What's it called?
The imitation game
There is a new nerdwriter episode every Wednesday.
Guys, so if you click that box that I've set up for you right over there
You'll get a... You'll get the videos. You'll get them. You'll get all the videos.  If you get that a little bell on mobile
I think you'll get notified when I release something new so do that too. Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
This video they make sleek intuitive website designs for you to customize and you don't have to know coding to make a really beautiful one
If you sign up for a year, you can get a free domain name and if you use the offer code nerdwriter
You can get 10% off your first purchase, so that's pretty cool. Thank you so much
I will see the rest of you next Wednesday. That was a weird end screen. I think I'm going to use it